does they do sense the moments when to
attack
when to work out long complicated
variations but also when to take a step
back
oh there's someone in magnus carlsen's
room obviously he's been waving away
don't come in oh
yeah he don't want to be taken cheating
i wouldn't be cheating if someone else
is in the room
all right well uh i think that was fine
then it seemed he got them out
very quickly maybe was that well because
we know he's staying somewhere
outside of norway he's somewhere warm
probably in a hotel
maybe was the cleaning people there's
pool cleaners
yeah your best friends these days david
you stayed in a hotel in norway for
wow oh he's waving again the cleaners
won't leave him
uh yeah you are you having trouble with
that as well david cleaners coming in
all the time
yeah you mentioned it the cleaners have
become my best friends i've been in the
same hotel room now for two months
and i know them by their first names i
know their kids names
it's getting a bit worrying they're so
nice well that's what it's like in a
pandemic
not many other people to meet so david
loving the cleaners
magnus crawls i'm not so much fun of
them right now it seems
the players are actually on on a
separate call as well
so that and i see magnus's huge reaction
here when
someone came into the room um we don't
know if it is the cleaners but we could
uh
we could maybe think that that is it oh
no
i don't want cleaning right now go out
anything to do no i don't want to trade
these queens
maybe that was it secret